es el mayor número de emigrantes desde
texas a nueva york este martes llegaron
cuatro autobuses enviados por el
gobernador republicano cree cabo
stavanger en fort y equipo creo que hay
al menos 140 personas el recuento
oficial no está hecho su viaje de 26 a
48 horas desde texas hasta nueva york a
veces con muy poca comida o sin nada
muchas familias llegaron con niños muy
pequeños
efe
muchos aunque todavía se desconoce la
nacionalidad de los migrantes a su
llegada a la gran manzana éstos
expresaron lo difícil que fue llegar
hasta allí catastrófico realmente éste
yo estuve en peligro de aborto ella en
méxico
fue muy duro porque tampoco recibo ayuda
aquí es inmigración me dieron ayuda en
el hospital hasta el momento el gobierno
estatal de texas en manos de los
republicanos ha fletado cientos de
autobuses para trasladar a seis mil
personas que llegaron desde méxico el
objetivo que los alcaldes demócratas y
el gobierno federal asuma la
responsabilidad de los migrantes un
compromiso firme para las autoridades
neoyorquinas
el gobernador bote está utilizando a
seres humanos inocentes como armas de
guerra eso está mal continuamos esas
acciones pero la ciudad está aquí para
dar la bienvenida a la gente
proporcionarles el apoyo que necesitan y
apoyar a su llegada especialmente a los
más vulnerables a los niños a las
familias a los que no son muy
conscientes de por qué han sido traídos
a la ciudad de nueva york
a poco más de tres meses de las
elecciones de mitad de mandato donde los
republicanos aspiran a retomar el
control del legislativo
la migración vuelve una vez más a entrar
como tema de campaña